إذا لم تحصل على أي عمليات في إفريقيا ، فأنت
بحاجة إلى تقديم سلسلة القيمة الكاملة
[موسيقى].
مرحبًا ، أنا مايك ريدفيلد ، أنا رئيس قسم
الاستماع لعمليات جنوب إفريقيا جنوب الصحراء
ومدير إدارة
عمليات Arneson egypt ، فأنت
مسؤول عنه  منطقة أفريقيا جنوب الصحراء
أيضًا ، لديك محفظة ضخمة جدًا
ولكن أبيض مصر الأبيض يأتي إلى
هنا بعد التوجه إلى جنوب إفريقيا ، ما
هو التفكير ، ما هي الإستراتيجية
حينها عندما ننظر إلى مصر 100 مليون
شخص ستة زائد ستة بالمائة زائد  نمو الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
الذي تبلغ قيمته ana TR من خلال سيارة trv
165 ألفًا فقط ، نرى إمكانات هائلة
لقد استثمرناها هنا على مدار السنوات
العشر الماضية كشركة
مصنعة كاملة وأحد الأهداف الرئيسية
هو معرفة كيف يمكننا تحقيق
الإمكانات الكاملة لـ  الصناعة الأخرى
في مصر ، وبالنسبة لنا ، لدينا
عملية تصنيع في جنوب إفريقيا ،
وأخرى في مصر ، ولنرى كيف
يمكننا إنشاء أوجه تآزر في جميع
أنحاء الرأس إلى القاهرة ، فإن الأمر
يبدو منطقيًا من منظور السيارات.
بعدة طرق مختلفة بأكثر من طريقة
ولكن الحقيقة هي أنك
لن تصنع سيارات في كل
بلد في إفريقيا ، ما نحتاج إلى فعله
هو إيجاد طريقة
لتدفق المكونات
والبلدان المختلفة  يمكن أن تلعب أدوارًا مختلفة
لأن المكونات هي المحرك
الحقيقي لخلق فرص العمل أو صانع سيارات ذي قيمة مضافة في
الوقت الحالي في مصر ، وهو صانع سيارات أصلي ، فما هو
حجمك في مصر في الوقت الحالي ، فنحن
بالفعل رقم اثنين في مصر
لدينا حوالي 14٪  شارك ما
هو مهم في ما نقوله
للحكومة المصرية التي كنا نناقشها
معهم هو إعطائنا الإطار ،
أعطنا السياسة التي نحن على استعداد للاستثمار ، نرى
إمكانات هائلة ،
كيف هو سوق السيارات المستعملة ، لكنني
متأكد من ذلك.  أنها كبيرة جدًا
وهي مكان مهم للتواجد فيه أيضًا ، فهي
سوق نابضة بالحياة للغاية إذا نظرنا إلى
متوسط عمر المركبات على الطريق وف
مصر أيضًا على مدار 10 سنوات ، الجزء الجيد هو
صر ومثل جنوب إفريقيا مثل ال
غرب  لا  السيارات المستعملة التي يتم
استيرادها إلى البلاد ، لذلك فهي
تخلق بدائل ميسورة التكلفة ،
والتنقل هو كل شيء عن الحرية الاقتصادية
، أنا فضولي فقط لأنك تعرف إلى أي
مدى يعيق استيراد السيارات المستعملة
في الكثير من الأسواق الأفريقية
تقدمك على ما أعتقد  إنه
الموضوع الشائع طوال الوقت أنه إذا أردنا
تطوير صناعة سيارات في سوق السيارات
في إفريقيا ، فعلينا إيقاف
الواردات الرمادية والرمادية المستعملة القادمة إلى
المغرب ، جنوب إفريقيا ، لقد فعلت مصر
ذلك بنجاح كبير ، لكن بالتأكيد إذا
نظرنا إلى نيجيريا حيث الإجمالي
من المحتمل أن يكون السوق لـ 500000 مركبة
في العام الماضي ، كان عدد المركبات الجديدة من خلال
قنوات om المشروعة 10000
وسوق يضم 200 مليون شخص ، لذا فإن
الإمكانات موجودة ولكنها تتطلب
إرادة سياسية قوية لوضع
تلك الحواجز في الواقع لقول ما يكفي من
المال ، فلنحافظ على المستخدم بالخارج  ودعونا
نرى كيف يمكننا تنمية سوقنا والسوق المحلي